no look here from steph curry in the
open court you got the joker running the
floor
for the young fella
here's steph from the corner wide open
there you go
way to listen to your coach
and the greatest shooter this game has
ever seen
the shot the turnaround the little
shimmy
listening to his head coach c webb
lebron
[Applause]
not fair please it's not fair
it's just such a big reason why this
game has changed
but it's changed about 10 feet up from
curry
paul and lillard at the backcourt for
team lebron and it's
curry again from distance
steph curry back in there
curry tries to backtrack
and fires from near side again
come on man oh sequence look at this is
good defense okay pressure ball he loses
it look he laughs
he laughs and then just says okay
inbound a 17-2 run
anna it is steph curry
way to hang on the real step like a big
fella
twelve straight makes by team lebron
we know the threes but now he's just
shocked come on
what's the deal with these boys 2021.
it's little to little oops all night
threes and a half
seven by russell westbrook and by kawhi
leonard
number seven anything you can do
i can do better mr lillard and here's
curry firing away